serving new evidence is emerging in the
case against the man charged with
murdering a missing Colorado mother
investigators revealed the dramatic
details in testimony yesterday Jamie
yuccas was in the courtroom in [ __ ]
Creek Colorado Jamie good morning good
morning after a preliminary hearing here
that lasted for hours a judge ruled
Patrick Frazee
will stand trial the gruesome testimony
from investigators hinged on their
conversations with crystal Kenny
the woman Frazee was allegedly having an
affair with Patrick Frazee showed no
emotion Tuesday as prosecutors presented
stunning evidence of how he allegedly
murdered the mother of his one-year-old
daughter to investigators recounted with
32 year-old crystal Jean Lee Kenny told
them including that she had a romantic
relationship with Frazee and that he
confessed to killing Kelsie Bharath at
her home on Thanksgiving Krystal then
tells us Patrick kills Kelsie in a
horrific manner Kenny told police that
Frazee convinced Bharath to wrap a
sweater around her head and guess the
scent of candles he then beat birth to
death with a baseball bat
after he has put Kelsie in a black
plastic tote calls Krystal to come out
and help him clean up Kenny left her
home in Idaho and drove to Barry's house
to clean up almost two days later when
she walks into Kelsey's condo the scene
is horrific there's blood everywhere
10 days after her alleged murder it was
Barry's brother who spotted blood and
called investigators Kenny testified she
watched as Frazee burned Barris remains
at his home Kenny said initially Frazee
asked her to kill the 29 year old mother
three times including by poisoning her
coffee earlier this month
Kenny pleaded guilty to tampering with
evidence in the case
Kenny's close friend Michele Stein told
his Kenny feared for her life she had
very very good reasoning for whatever it
is she may or may not have done
I asked prosecutors why Kenny never
called police
while constrained by what they can
discuss it was indicated in court
Kenny feared for the lives of her
children a motive has also not been
disclosed but Beres parents allege in a
lawsuit that Frazee killed their
daughter over a custody dispute Frazee
has not entered a plea his arraignment
though scheduled now for April Nora
all right those details difficult to
hear Jamie thank you